[Music]
the word
cryptid refers to any entity whose
existence has yet to be documented
outside of legends and myth like the
loch ness monster
but believe it or not many real animals
you might recognize
today were once cryptids themselves
thought to exist
only in folklore as humankind has
explored more and more remote parts of
our planet's surface however
increasingly fantastical organisms have
been discovered
so for this entry into the archives
we're going to catalog
seven real animals once upon a time
thought to be cryptids
in the darkness of the ocean a leviathan
lurks
for centuries sailors made reports of a
colossal
tentacled monster which emerged from the
depths to drag
ships to their watery demise referred to
in scandinavian folklore as the kraken
for most of human history these supposed
sea monsters were thought to be
nothing more than a myth today however
scientists believe
these tales emerge from early sightings
of
giant squids since the first footage of
a live adult giant squid wasn't captured
until the 2000s
it's no surprise these creatures were
considered to be
fictitious monsters for so long they
don't actually smash boats
but since these cephalopods can grow up
to 13 meters
or 43 feet in length it's not surprising
these behemoths were once considered
true monsters
additionally the animals have the
largest eyes of any living creature
about the size of a dinner plate they
also have a donut-shaped brain that
their esophagus passes
through the middle of on the way to
their stomach in a way
it would almost make more sense if giant
squids were
only the stuff of legends besides the
kraken one of the most recognizable
aquatic cryptids is the sea serpent
taking on various forms in numerous
cultures
sea serpents are usually long scaly
monsters sometimes sporting a finned
ridge going down their back
although such a monster seems like it
could only exist in myth
there is one real species which
scientists consider to be a probable
source of many sea serpent tails
the oarfish is a massive deep sea
organism which swims at such a low depth
it's challenging to capture footage of
one while a fish
not a serpent the oarfish can reach
lengths of 8 meters or 26 feet
in length during storms these giants
sometimes
washed up on the shore which is likely
where ancient humans first encountered
them
in some rare cases however the oarfish
has been spotted
swimming in shallow tropical waters a
site which is the closest you'll ever
get to observing a
real sea serpent moving on to land
another large reptilian cryptid that
appears in the folklore of many cultures
is the dragon four limbed fire-breathing
monsters with a serpentine appearance
true dragons might only exist in old
tomes but there's a real world animal
that gets
pretty close komodo dragons aren't the
origin of most dragon myths but when
they were first reported on
it's no surprise people were at first
skeptical of these accounts of massive
scaly beasts which seemed right out of
an ancient legend
growing up to a length of 3 meters or 10
feet the largest lizards on the planet
aren't that far off from
actual dragons they might not breathe
fire but they do produce
toxic proteins from lands in their lower
jaw
not an animal you want to encounter
returning to the open waters
krakens and sea serpents weren't the
only fantastic creatures sailors told
tales of
many also made references to mermaids
the fish-tailed sirens of the deep
but these sightings were in fact
inspired by glimpses of a real animal
the manatee manatees are herbivorous
marine mammals which look
decidedly not like people although they
feature unique paddle
shaped tails which do tangentially
resemble the mermaids of legend
the sailors who spotted these creatures
likely only saw them from a distance
and had maybe spent too much time alone
on their boats
mermaids are not manatees are great play
a vital role in their ecosystem
and must be protected moving inland i
want you to imagine
a dense forest now imagine a large
furry unknown animal which sometimes can
be spotted walking on two legs
like a human if your mind first went to
bigfoot i'd understand
but these are actually the details of a
completely different primate species
that was once unknown to science the
mountain gorilla
crazy right today the existence of
gorillas seems obvious
but if you try to imagine getting a
report of gigantic
hairy upright walking animals hiding in
heavily forested mountains you might
start to sympathize more with any
initial doubters of these creatures
existence
some early accounts suggested they were
violent carnivores and although there
are no pushovers
they're much more likely to munch on a
carrot than munch on a passerby
gorillas are an amazing yet endangered
species which needs to be safeguarded
or they might pass into genuine myth
down in the continent of australia
we have some of the most unique animals
on earth but perhaps none is quite so
strange as a certain duck-billed
egg-laying mammal which was for years
thought to just be a mythical cryptid
i'm of course talking about the platypus
unlike other species on this list nobody
mistook the platypus for some
existing mythical monster because
frankly even things out of myth don't
look as weird as the platypus
instead for years many simply believed
the animal was a hoax or an amalgamation
of different animal sightings
what an incredible species and to close
off our list
we have not an animal but a plant early
records of venus fly traps were met with
skepticism and considering they're a
plant which essentially eats insects
with their mouth like leaves one can
understand why
the idea of hoards of snapping plants
which catch live prey does sound
pretty far-fetched and pretty horrifying
the way venus flytraps work is they
possess
tiny hair-like triggers which go off
when insects land on them releasing a
signal to trap them
inside the plants then digest the bugs
using a unique set of enzymes and
honestly
if that's not the closest thing to a
documented cryptid
i don't know what is so those are seven
animals
well six animals in one plant that are
no longer the stuff of myth
if you enjoyed this video please
consider leaving a like
subscribing and pressing the
notification icon to stay up to date
with curious archive
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you in the next video
you